[music playing]
[glass hitting metal]
[light scraping sound]
[violin playing]
[LIGHT CRASH OF GLASS INTO
METAL]
[footsteps]
[side conversation]
ALBERT: Miss Maric.
MILEVA: Are you under
the impression you're
the only one in the building?
ALBERT: Sorry,
did I disturb you?
MILEVA: Your
playing is adequate,
but it makes it quite
difficult to concentrate.
ALBERT: Apologies.
Mozart helps me think.
MILEVA: I'm not
sure this assignment
requires much thought.
ALBERT: Well, not
if we were to follow
these inelegant instructions.
There must be a better
approach, don't you think?
MILEVA: I think following
the instructions
is the way to pass the class.
ALBERT: Is that all you
want from an education,
to pass your exams?
MILEVA: I want a
degree, don't you?
ALBERT: Certainly, but
I'm a student of science
because, well, I
want to discover
new ways of understanding
the world around me.
Don't you already know
how this will turn out?
MILEVA: I find knowing how
it will turn out reassuring.
Discover quietly, Herr Einstein.
Please.
[winding noise]
[hiss]
[explosion]
ALBERT: Oh.
Ow.
Ah.